Next, we'll talk about the difference between parent and instance materials and how to add
a few more features to those functionalities as well. So we'll review parent materials
and instance materials to begin with. We'll talk about creating some switch parameters
for instance and so you can really dial in the result of what you want a specific instance
to look like. And we'll talk about creating a master material, a UV control for instance
So let's just review the parent materials and the instance in concept. So when to use it and what
and why is it useful? So you'll see that we have parent material on the right hand side here. We've
got color value. In this example, we've decided to create a metallic value and also a roughness
value. And we've plugged those into the respective inputs. Now you'll see that these are all
parameters. You'll see in the slight italicized text below, it says param, param, and param. And
that essentially means it's a parameter that we can use to change the result outside of the parent
material. So on the left hand side here, you'll see an instance version of this material. And on
the top properties, you'll see that we've got the albedo ticks, we've got the normal ticks,
and we've got the roughness ticks. And we can dial in these values based on the instanced
version of that. So we've created one material here that has parameters that we can change. And on
the instance, we can make subtle tweaks and shifts. Sometimes we want to make large shifts
and tweaks. But essentially, you don't have to create a material from scratch. You can just
change the values that you wanted to change based on the parameter of the master parent material.
So we can think about adding a little bit more functionality to these materials. The previous
example was a little bit more of a basic that you'd expect to see in any given Unreal project. Now
let's think about how we might switch based on some of these parameters. So we can import a desired
texture, whatever you'd like, and we'll prompt you at the end of this section to create your own.
So if we just go through the notes to begin with, and then you can pause the video and try and
recreate this yourself. So you import some kind of desired material, we'll right click and search
for a switch parameter. So if you just right click in the material graph, type in switch parameter,
you'll have a static switch parameter that will appear there. And then you just want to select
that. And then we can create several constraints and plug them into the false node. So if you
want to create a const, you can hold down one on your keyboard and left mouse click and that will
create a const one. Alternatively, you can just find the constants in the right click menu.
Scale parameters, in a similar way, scale parameters are constants nodes that have been
converted to a parameter. So once we've created that const, so we maybe held down number one on
our keyboard, we left clicked, you can actually right click on that new node that you created and
convert it to a parameter. And therefore you'll then be able to give it a name. By default,
it'll just be a numerical value. But if you want it to be a parameter, you can right click and
convert that to a parameter. So we want to convert all the texture sample nodes to parameters,
including any constants parameters, they will now become scalar parameters for you to assign
names to that we'll be able to communicate with in an instance version of this material.
If we want to think about creating a master material with UV control, let's maybe add a UV
coordinate. So just right click UV coordinate. And this is a text coordinate in this example,
we want to create two multiply expressions. So we've got one multiply here, one multiply there,
you can actually hold down M for multiply on the keyboard. And to create a multiply there,
we can create an append expression, we can create three scalar parameters, again, just holding down
one on the keyboard for each one and convert them to a parameter, and then connect them to each
texture UV desired. So just a note on this last section here, you'll see the comment box there
as well. But the last multiply acts as a bridge and can be an ad instead. So if you'd like to
create an ad instead of a multiply, you can do that. And it will simply shift the UVs whilst
multiply shifts and increases the scale. So keep in mind and depends on the design effect of what
you would like your material to look like. To create the instance version of the material,
so we've got this new material in our content browser, you'll see it wherever you created it
in the folder, you can actually right click on this master or parent material and create a
material instance based on that parent material. When you do a new material will be created,
but it'll be a material instance instead of an actual just master material. And we can load up
this instance and you'll see some kind of box like this, it'll have different parameters based
on what you had created in the previous example. But it'll allow you to tick certain parameters on
and off of the properties that you want to edit based on the material that you're trying to create.
So instances are used to prevent constant recompiling of shaders because we've got this
parent or master material. That's what's doing all your shader compilation. It knows what to
expect from the PBR system that you're trying to create. And therefore every instance is just
based on that parent shader. So Unreal knows to calculate certain parameters and then it's just
dialing in the specific result that you want. So we can make the instance from the master material,
we can open the instance, click the nose to activate them, swap out any textures you would
like and it gives you a lot more freedom and flexibility. And it's also just less performant,
well it's more performant but less heavy on performance to take this approach. So maybe
it's worth jumping in now into your editor. Maybe think about creating a new parent material with
some switch parameters. You could create the UV parameter control as we just went over in the
video. And maybe just test them out, test that workflow, see, get familiar with it. It's a concept
that you'll use in all your Unreal projects. It's just a very streamlined way of working,
it allows a lot of flexibility and it's just a useful pipeline to know and understand moving forward.